[Música]
la faufarria los tambores de rochan
Alegría en el centro de Río de Janeiro y
eso a pesar de que son las 7 de la
mañana la calle está repleta de personas
disfrazadas de todas las edades
hay mucha pasión por la fiesta por el
carnaval creo que nacemos con ella y
esta comparsa es la cosa más linda que
hay en Río de Janeiro
a cordón del boitatá y está inspirado en
un personaje del folklore brasileño es
una serpiente de fuego que protege a los
animales y a los bosques de los que
quieren destruirlos es algo muy actual
en Brasil
los cariocas son famosos por su ironía a
la hora de crear los disfraces
Shakira descubrió la tradición de Piqué
porque su tarro de mermelada estaba más
vacío y a Piqué y a sus hijos no les
gustaba la mermelada Entonces se dio
cuenta de que alguien estaba comiendo su
mermelada cada año creo un disfraz nuevo
el disfraz tiene que estar ligado a la
actualidad Y ser divertido
la sátira política es algo intrínseco al
carnaval de Río de Janeiro y la
referencia a los ataques de Brasilia no
podía faltar
a tus padres
yo represento a Los Patriotas que se
quedaron acampados durante 60 días
esperando en realidad una intervención
alcohólica ellos no esperaban una
intervención militar es por eso que
nuestro lema es Carnaval encima de todo
y cachaza dentro de todos
cucharitas de plástico y otros objetos
cotidianos se transforman en trajes
originales y hasta musicales el carnaval
aquí no es solo diversión es también
creatividad tradición y sensualidad